je m'appelle Lizzie et son médecin je suis
originaire de Pendleton je vis maintenant
dans une guitare avec mon mari et ma famille
et je travaille pour le collège en tant
qu'éducatrice d'adultes je le fais depuis 10 ans
maintenant et j'adore ça  ce cours est une
conception et une production de fourrure d'abord c'est une
mer de préparation de peau tout le phoque a
été découpé écorché nettoyé gratté
étiré bien que tout le processus de
peaux de phoque ait été fait les trois premières semaines
et maintenant tout est confection de
patrons traditionnels et la
couture traditionnelle  les techniques sont les
dernières en ce moment beaucoup de nos
élèves cousent leur peau et se préparent
aux produits chimiques peu d'entre nous ont
appris les techniques de ces styles
pour faire des bandes dessinées à la maison parce que nous sommes dans le
système scolaire maintenant c'est les devoirs et
autres  activités en cours dans la
communauté, nous avons déconnecté la façon dont nos
mères font leur maigre
la relation ici est géniale comme
tout le monde ici parle notre langue notre
langue maternelle dans l'attitude et  nous l'
encourageons tellement, surtout lorsque
nous faisons la couture pratique, notre
instructrice est une aînée respectée
et quand elle parle, c'est généralement sa
langue le matin peu sur les planches,
nous avons une liste de glossaire terminologique,
nous apprenons en fait de nouveaux mots notre énergie
deux mots  que nous avons perdu en cours de route
oubliez de faire un don ou amico trachéal
mon nom est régulier je ne suis pas coca je suis de
quicken law je suis l'instructeur pour le
programme de conception qui se tient ici
au Delta College nous sommes partis de la droite
depuis le début du viol du panneau en
peau de phoque, nous les étirons et les
séchons à l'extérieur c'est traditionnel pour nous
je le fais depuis tant d'années
et ce sont les meilleurs pour le nord à
porter surtout en hiver et pour
les gars  qui va chasser ce que nous
faisons est mouillé dans la zone et juste
ramasser avec la plus grande difficulté que nous
appelons cet outil et enlever la tache
de sang sec là-bas une fois que tout ce qui est nettoyé
sur les deux peaux est la première chose que nous
devons  faire est d'attacher l'extrémité ou le bord de
toute la peau et d'en faire un énorme
type de balle pour la peau intérieure à l'extérieur et
quelle est la taille de la balle va être grosse, elle
sera grosse une fois qu'elle une fois que nous la transformerons en
balle feiss  nous allons piétiner dessus
nous allons danser dessus tout ce que je
piétine sur la peau rend cette partie de la peau
plus flexible une fois qu'il est assez facile de
travailler avec nous avons toujours cet
outil dur et nous grattons la partie sèche et le
rendons  dans une peau plus lisse non pas
parce que je veux juste dire au
plus jeune aujourd'hui que je voudrais que
vous gardiez les vêtements traditionnels non
vivants, je ne vous livre pas parce
qu'ils sont les meilleurs pour le nord
quel est le but du  une sorte de rêve
que vous avez pour vos élèves une fois que
cela est terminé, cela dépend essentiellement de chaque
élève, Susie a dit qu'elle voulait
apprendre à faire des bandes dessinées pour sa famille
après que les élèves aient atteint leur
objectif à court terme, vous ne savez jamais si
leur objectif peut  devenir plus loin
quelque part
c'est comme ça  va regarder ce n'est pas tout à
propos de la peau c'est à propos de tout
c'est ce que nous avons été élevé
c'est ce que nous allons le garder ici et
c'est comme ça que nous allons le faire dans une
salle de classe